if you want a new twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili
my next recipe is super simple to make
but has wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors
spicy beef salad chilis if you use them
confidently
they can really add a new dimension to
the style of cooking but
the real trick is finding that balance
of flavors that really suits you
because that's the most important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin
you can see it's got that wonderful
marble for me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper push that seasoning
in to the sirloin take the third one out
the fridge literally 20 minutes before
you want to cook them so it gets up to
room temperature they cook more evenly
but more importantly you can actually
season right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that
is what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered
olive oil in a tablespoon roll that
round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan and lay away
again into the pan and lay away if you
don't hear that noise
the minute those steaks hit the pan
don't put them in so the secret now is
getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half minutes
each side what i want to do is to get
that bit of fat
rendered so it adds a lot more flavor
just hold
the steak down like that and that starts
to melt the fat which makes it
so much more tender there should be no
white fat left anywhere
turn them over really important to have
that steak up to room temperature before
you start cooking it so the inside
is nice and warm so we spend less time
in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in says rare i'm happy for them
to be rare because by the time i let
them rest
they're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking
out onto a plate and let them rest
one two
let's get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands
and tapping until the seeds fall out cut
it in half
and just chop it in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it
get your knife and just slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub start going around in circles first
you'll see it puring
nice clear that off now we've got the
heat in there from the chilli
and that richness from the garlic two
teaspoons of palm sugar
this is where it starts to have that
nice sweet sour
effect fish sauce
fresh lime this is a simple fresh chili
dressing and it was something i fell in
love with in vietnam
and cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar
quick taste
wow right vegetables a great fuss-free
way to get super thin ribbons of carrot
is to use a veg peeler when they're that
thin
they take the vinaigrette so much better
and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad i'm gonna use a banana shallot
they are incredibly mellow very sweet
across just chop up
the shallot and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes
slice them in half tomatoes in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber chopped
spring onions
and shred baby gem lettuce and then
finally
get some fresh mint there's young men so
you don't need to take all those stalks
off all you do is hold the bunch upside
down
and then take it for a little trim
and just chop that once through
you've got that nice minted salad
a couple of tablespoons of dressing
don't flood the cellar with a dressing
we can always add but we can't take it
away now really mix that dressing in
there
make sure all that chili and garlic and
palm sugar
wraps around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steak's rested it's
now nice and medium rare
that little bit of fat we don't want to
find that in the salad just slice that
off
that serves its purpose it's kept that
steak nice and moist
just slice going with the grain it's
almost like
slicing through butter and look inside
beautiful pink you slice the beef too
thinly then it goes stone cold
and more importantly all the goodness
runs out of it nice thick
slices get the beef and start placing it
around and sell it take a little
teaspoon
of your dressing the rest of your salad
sip that on top
we'll finish it off with some toasted
peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts are really toasted nuts
on get another pan
and just crush
once they've cooled down just run them
through with a knife you can hear how
crunchy they are
another texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally take that just finish
it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce and there is
one tasty
very well textured spicy beef salad
first up pasta with tomatoes anchovies
and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice anchovies and
garlic
[Music]
next dried chilies great for keeping in
the cupboard add a hit of heat on demand
[Music]
then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan
and fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes chopped black
olives
and salted capers cooked to combine the
flavours
in a separate pan boiled dried spaghetti
another great store-covered staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain
add to the sauce with a splash of the
water it's full of starch which gives a
great silky consistency
then season with pepper and topped with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes
pasta with tomatoes anchovy and chilis
my next deliciously different chili
recipe is grilled corn with chipotle
chili butter
[Music]
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter soak chipotle
chilies in hot water
these are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
mix together and season
[Music]
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over
lancashire cheese fantastically messy to
eat
grilled corn with chipotle chili butter
and utterly delicious smoky treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
start by making the intense jerk
marinade
first scotch bonnet chilis they may be
small but pack real heat and a fruity
punch then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves cinnamon
nutmeg and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
brown the marinaded chicken for 10
minutes
then add worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
finger licking good
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimal effort my first recipe
melts in the mouth and because the oven
does most of the work it's a cinch to
make
slow cooked fiery lamb cooking's all
about being bold and adventurous
and this dish is exciting because it's
slowly cooked and the longer it cooks
the more flavoursome it becomes
marinating the lamb first chilis we're
going to use a mixture of red
and green take off the tops and just
slice
in garlic
crushed don't worry about chopping these
ultra fine just
get it in there cooking for up to three
hours
everything sort of blends and almost
sort of purees itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilis
two teaspoons in a touch of dried
oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance
that they give out is extraordinary they
release a little oil as well
and helps to tenderize the lamb a touch
of salt
pepper cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil just a tablespoon
and the olive oil helps to sort of stick
all those wonderful spices
to the lamb jump in just start
really rubbing at this stage you can
leave the lamb to marinade for anything
from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results
when you tuck in delicious vegetables
carrots and onions and that's it sliced
secret slicing vegetables from braising
is not getting too thin
you slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible char
taste on that slow braise grazing it's
just a chef's term that means cooking in
liquid on a low heat
making the meat incredibly moist and
beautifully tender so the secret of
braising
is having a really nice thick durable
pan
get that nice and hot just a touch of
olive oil
lamb in hold the bone because you're in
control then
into the pan
i want that white fat to start rendering
so it'll add more fat therefore making
it
a lot more flavoursome as it braises
chilies cinnamon
in mix that up and don't be scared
you're not burning this you're sort of
searing the lamb shanks and this is the
important part right at the very
beginning
we're getting the color on the lamb
which washes off as it braises in the
oven so
be generous with that color vegetables
in
wow and then a couple of baileys
so now you lift the lamb up and get the
lamb
sat on top of the vegetables now just
glaze the pan with red wine
deglazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
can really transform that dish
always delays then bring to the boil and
cook for about 10 minutes to reduce
the wine is reduced down by half now for
the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now
don't cover it when you cover it all the
condensation comes off
the lid your lamb becomes gray all this
effort and that
exciting spice gets washed away no lid
and into the oven for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work
and transform the meat so it's
mouthwateringly tender
now look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat
sliding down juicy and then creamy
tender
grab it by the the shank roll around
that
rich delicious sauce
look at that and get your sauce
nice beautiful just get some mint
don't chop it just pick that fresh mint
and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank
amazing